This episode of "Shots
of Awe" is brought to you
by the Toyota Prius.
Let's lead the way.
So I'm a big fan of moments of
absolute aesthetic immersion.
When you get sucked into a film.
When you get caught up in an
environment that is completely
absorbing, and
you go into a kind
of trance, a kind of
liminal trance state.
You enter that
magical borderland
between dreams and
reality-- the space
of archetype, the space of
dream, the space of myth.
And so I recently picked up
a book by Allison Griffiths.
And this book was about the
uses of instructive media
throughout history to evoke
mind spaces of ecstatic worship.
So she basically
says that the IMAX
is the contemporary
equivalent of what
was once the Gothic Cathedral.
That these were immersive
technologies that
mediated our encounters
with transcendence,
our encounters with these
spaces of ecstatic worship.
And one of the things
that she talks about
is the revered gaze.
Now, the revered
gaze is that moment
in which we're sitting
back in the IMAX theater,
staring at the movie trailer
for "Interstellar" when they're
talking about how man is
going to leave it all behind,
and transcend, and he wasn't
meant to stay on earth.
And you're feeling that
cosmic awe, the wow,
the buzz of science fiction
in an immersive environment.
And it's just like, ah!
It's that feeling.
Or when you're in
the Gothic Cathedral
and for whatever reason,
I'm not religious,
but you're staring at the
beautiful colored glass
and the sun is coming in.
And maybe you're listening to
some phantasmagorical music
that's tripping you out.
That's the revered gaze.
That is a place of
ecstatic catharsis.
A moment of illumination.
And these moments in which
we so fully lose ourselves,
these ecstatic flow
states that shut down
the lateral prefrontal
cortex, shut down
to the sense of
self-awareness, it's
this apotheosis, this
death and rebirth.
That's what we seek in
aesthetic experiences.
It's what we seek in
transcendent experiences--
to smash our sense of
separateness in temples
of fragmentation in this
form of electronically
mediated Buddhism.
It's something that is
intrinsic to the human desire
to dream, and to lose
ourselves in the imagination.
And I think that the Oculus
Rift, virtual reality,
surround sound, all these
ways in which we mediate
these encounters,
these new exotic forms
of instructive media that
will continue to emerge,
they have this
historical context
that we've been doing it
for hundreds of years.
It's perfectly normal.
It's something that's
inside us and is driving us.
And, yeah, that's in a nutshell
why cinema is an altar.
That's why I love these
technologies of immersion.